[музика]
вітаємо це програма Європа У фокусі з
вами я Лара бабалола Ласкаво просимо дні
стають коротшими і холоднішими і зима
вже не за горами в Європі багатьом людям
в Україні така зміна пори року дається
нелегко використовуючи дрони та
артилерію Росія атакує українські
теплостанції та електромережі так само
як і Минулого року ці атаки спрямовані
на деморалізацію цивільного населення
мільйони людей бояться що їм знову
доведеться зіткнути з холодом без
електрики опалення та
водопостачання Анна з Харкова одна з
таких потерпілих її багатоквартирний
будинок було серйозно пошкоджено
Минулого року на початку російського
вторгнення відтоді Вона живе з матір'ю у
підвалі який втлів при обстрілах їхній
імпровізований дім забезпечує їм захист
від війни яка вирує на горі проте Анна
мріє повернутись до своєї оселі і тут до
справи береться він Дмитро та його
команда невтомно працюють над усуненням
руйнувань завданих війною хоча цей
виглядає нескінченною
справою передмістя
Харкова тут усе виглядає так само як і в
перші місяці війни коли передмісця
обстрілювали російські
війська будинки зазнали уражень з
артилерії і як повідомляють мешканці
навіть від ракет із
винищувачів ті хто залишився вже другу
зиму живуть без центрального опалення у
деяких квартирах навіть немає
вікон Анна вже 20 місяців живе у підвалі
свого багатоквартирного будинку разом із
матір'ю та подругою Тому що тут
тепліше ця стара дров'яна піч їхнє єдине
джерело тепла если потаплювать тогда так
а так конечно набагато холодніше ну ну
замерзнути не замерзнеш але краще чим у
квартирі котики у вас тут черозроби для
міста будинок Анни стоїть в кінці списку
пріоритетів тому що він занадто сильно
пошкоджений щоб його можна було швидко
відремонтувати багато мешканців цього
району опинилися у схожій ситуації і
вони не задоволені рішеннями
влади у центрі Харкова застосовується
так званий підхід швидкого
відновлення незначні пошкодження
усуваються Швидко щоб мешканцям не
доводилося надовго залишати свої будинки
а місця у міських пунктах тимчасового
розміщення можуть дістатися тим хто їх
дійсно
потребує на цій вулиці нещодавно
вибухнула російська ракета вона вибила
вікна майже в усіх
будинках найбільше Ми займаємося швидким
відновленням швидке відновлення - це
заміна вікон вивезення сміття лагодження
дохів мешканка цієї квартири наразі живе
зі своєю родиною команда проєкту
сподівається що вона зможе повернутися
незабаром вивести сміття і позабивати
вікна Мені здається що сьогодні ми точно
зможемо це
зробити коли відремонтують дорогу буде
важко сказати що в цей квартал поцілила
ракета але під час роботи команди
лунають сирени повітряної тривоги чи
відчувають волонтери що Їхня робота не
має
кінця
ми не знаємо напевно але ми готові до
всього Зараз ми робимо це знову і знову
але в майбутньому це
закінчиться Але ми не знаємо
коли однак нестача житла - це лише одна
з багатьох проблем які постають перед
українською владою з настанням
холодів минулої зими російські військові
використовували дрони та ракети
дальнього радіусу враження для нанесення
ударів по українській енергосистемі
це призвело до частих відключень
електроенергії по всій
країні але цього разу Україна краще
готова до російських атак інженери
відновлюють Сотні підстанцій І захищають
їх вибухостійким бетоном ці нові
конструкції не витримують прямого
влучання ракети але захистять від
осколків можливі там якісь будуть
пошкодження да Якщо там будуть якісь
враження але вони такі суттєві не будуть
ми можемо швидко відреагувати
відремонтувати цей об'єкт і ввести його
знову в
роботу крім того українські військові
планують розмістити свої засоби
протиповітряної оборони у ключових
точках енергетичної мережі це стосується
теплових електростанцій та великих
підстанцій таких як ця що забезпечує
електроенергію до півмільйона осель Але
незважаючи на всі ці зусилля енергетичну
інфраструктуру країни чекає важка зима
Росія зруйнувала багато дорогих
електростанцій а запчастини постачаються
лише
частково і це означає що стійкість в
цілому звісно нижча ніж до того як усе
це
почалося ми зараз десь
посередині з одного боку ми добре
підготувалися У нас є розуміння того що
відбулося Ми багато тренувалися і
готувалися з іншого боку З точки зору
обладнання ми знаходимося в слабшій
позиції експерт вважає що Росія більше
не вірить що може тиснути на Україну
атакуючи
інфраструктуру Я впевнений що буде важко
але ми
прорвемося як тільки відремонтують
центральне опалення Анна планує
повернутися на гору міська Влада
пообіцяла їй що це буде зроблено але не
назвала конкретної
дати підтримка перш за
все моральне
що як кажуть це для нас уже дуже ва
ми тут всі знаєте от інколи падаємо
духом трішки Ну як кажуть Спочатку це
якось не так відчувалося заразже трошки
все проходе Ми ждемо кінця війни а
її Анна хотіла б мати щось на що вона
могла б розраховувати тоді можливо
пережити зимові місяці було б
легше життя Владислава Шахова
кардинально змінила
війнапочатку український солдат отримав
важке пора захищаючи свою країну від
Росії потім він став одним із близько
800 українців яких вивезли на лікування
до Німеччини А тепер коли Владислав
одужує він бореться з бюрократією в
Німеччині його підтримує Анжела шарлау
волонтерка яка опікується пораненими
солдатами з України Німеччина пообіцяла
покрити всі витрати на лікування але
Анжела бачить скільки стресу викликає у
її підопічних бюрократична
тяганина ли шарла у вихідний але
доглядальниця займається волонтерством у
свій вільний час вона доглядає за
пораненим українським солдатом який
цього потребує Він проходить лікування в
клініці за межами Берліна найбільша
проблема Анжели німецька
бюрократія більшість із цих солдатів
були поранені більше року тому вони
лежали в українському госпіталі із
серйозними пораненнями і не отримували
ніякої фінансової підтримки від України
потім вони приїжджають сюди і стикаються
з німецькою бюрократією вони прикуті до
ліжок вони не можуть покинути лікарню
але при цьому змушені обходити
управління соціального захисту центру
зайнятості і хто зна Які ще
установи Владислава важко поранило
осколком гранати він частково
паралізований 25тирічний хлопець майже
нічого не може робити без сторонньої
допомоги про особисту присутність на
всіх офіційних зустрічах не може бути
мови Анжела та інші волонтери займаються
його документами сьогодні вони також
привезли владиславу деякі подарунки
дуже багато що значить потому що Если би
не ці люди Ми б не змогли Тут даже так
подать ці документи і справиться ВСМ як
вони
допомагають Владислав зараз
натаіреабіліції хотів би знати що його
чекає після лікування
ну розмовляв з врачами вони
кажуть те що в таком состоянії дуже буде
тяжело вийти е ну надіюся на лучше
карола туман очолює соціальний відділ
цієї клініки вона контактує з медичними
страховими компаніями державними
установами та іншими органами влади аби
забезпечити підтримку таким пацієнтам як
Владислав після завершення лікування
Владислав уже два місяці немає
страхового
полісу у нього ще немає житла він досі
перебуває в лікарні його випадком
займається районний офіс Але ми не
можемо ні з ким там зв'язатися нам
кажуть що передзвонять а потім не
передзвонюють так триває вже два місяці
Владислав хоче вийти покурити але йому
потрібна допомога щоб дістатися до місця
для
курців міська Влада Берліна опікується
приблизно 30ма такими ж пораненими
українцями як і він але пробитися крізь
усі бюрократичні перепони справа не
злегких на всіх них виділили лише двох
офіційних
помічників Вони теж люди вони працюють
із 9ї ранку до 6стої вечора після 18ї з
ними не можна зв'язатися але солдати
мають свої проблеми 24 години на добу 7
днів на тиждень Ми зв'язалися з
берлінським відділом охорони здоров'я
щоб запитати про ситуацію з українськими
солдатами але вони відмовились від
коментарів Анжела принесла владиславу
весільні фотографії він знає цю щасливу
пару спочатку Меделін просто хотіла
допомагати але потім між волонтеркою і
Андрієм ще одним пораненим солдатом який
приїхав до Німеччини розгорілося
справжнє
коханняі на весіллі були присутні інші
Українці які живуть тут в еміграції Ми
дуже багато читали про Андрія в газетах
він неймовірна людина він дуже си дуже
сильний відважний і ми пишаємося тим що
він є що він захищає нас і хочемо його
підтримати Андрій надалі потребуватиме
інвалідного візка але він не втрачає
оптимізму Дуже дякую
Чесно кажучи дуже багато що змінилося
після останніх подій скажемо щосно не
планував одружуватися
А треба кудись рухатись життя повні
повністю повністю змінилось після
пораненя Хай буде
так попереду в Андрія ще дві операції
після останньої з них клініка попросила
його заплатити особисто хоча український
уряд запевняв його Що про це вже
домовились знайшов контакти до цього
чувака який до мене дзвонив з мозу
подзвонив кажу В мене така ситуація як
це вирішувати він каже ну збов'язання за
платити за реабілітацію Взяла на себе
Німецька сторона волонтери вже написали
численним політикам Та відповідальним
особам скаржачись на бюрократичні
перепони Та
плутанину це в принципі погано Коли ти
приїжджаєш до Німеччини навіть просто як
звичайний біженець а очікувати цього Від
людей в інвалідних війзках які втратили
руку чи щось іще гірше це взагалі
абсурд
усі тут сподіваються що ситуація скоро
покращиться принаймні весілля Меделін та
Андрія - це привід для
[музика]
Надії Європа сильно залежить від імпорту
рідкоземельних металів таких як літій та
олово обидва ці метали важливі
компоненти зокрема для смартфонів та
електромобілів але насправді ті ресурси
тут не такі вже рідкісні експерти
металургійної галузі звернули свою увагу
на південний захід Англії де є величезні
ліцію генеральний директор конішal рчард
ульямс говорить про початок нової ери
гірничо-добувної промисловості у
Великобританії у минулому тутешня
гірнича добувна промисловість заробляла
свої статки за рахунок видобутку вугілля
зараз цеє сектор який вже майже занепав
переживає
відродження на узбережжі корнуола досі
помітні сліди гірничово добувної історії
Британії цей регіон Багатий на корисні
копалини які десятилі тми нікому не були
потрібні зараз вони знову користуються
великим
попитом на глибині 50 м під землею стара
шахта відроджується У рамках проекту
саукровt teн гірничодобувної компанії
cornish metals генеральний директор
компанії Річард Вільямс хоче відродити
ці шахти і видобувати тут олово у
великих масштабах наразі Китай
найбільший виробник олова на світовому
ринку Річард хотів би бачити більше про
ці із Великої Британії та корнула це
ресурс олова найвищого гатунку у світі
який наразі не Видобувається це четверте
за якістю родовище олова про яке ми
знаємо у світі це велика річ і я думаю
що це ще раз відображає якість цього
району в корнулі з точки зору
мінералізації
олова від смартфонів до вітряків олово
використовується практично в усіх
електронних
пристроях corніish metals наразі оцінює
розмір цього
родовища також мета полягає у тому щоб
зменшити залежність Британії від
Китаю Ми пройшли через період очевидно
через російське вторнення в Україну і те
що відбувається між Китаєм і тайванем
коли є набагато більше занепокоєня з
приводу безпеки поставок і внутрішнього
виробництва і ми вважаємо що корнул
враховуючи його багаторічну гірничо
видобовну історію а це одна з найбільших
колов'яних провінцій світу може
відігравати важливу роль в постачанні
олова не лише до Великої Британії але й
до Європи
загалом це питан настільки важливе що
британський уряд виділив кошти на
підтримку таких проєктів у корнувалі
Велика Британія представила свою
стратегію щодо критично важливих
корисних копалин Минулого року навіть
раніше ніж ЄС ідеться про забезпечення
більш стійких ланцюгів поставок ніж
зараз це запорука того що ми не будемо
покладатися лише на одну чи дві країни
світу у постачанні критично важливих
мінералів для нашого передового
виробничого сектору звісно Ми також
розглядаємо як ми можемо видобувати
корисні копалини на місцево ріні а також
переробляти очищати їх та виготовляти з
них продукцію поточний фокус на
відновлюваних джерелах енергії спричинив
стрімке зростання попиту на найважливіші
мінеральні ресурси і в корноволі
реалізується ще один великий проект
майбутнього літієвий нещодавно у
корновалі було виявлено значні запаси
літію важливого елемента для електричних
батарей для автомобілів як
пропрасювається
буріння це все ще тестовий об'єкт але
генеральний директор britшлітum ндрю
Сміт вважає що вони зможуть покрити
третину потреб Великої Британії Всього
за 5пть років алмазний бур заглиблюється
на 700 м під поверхню для видобутку
граніту який містить так зване біле
золото тут купа мінералів тут є кварц
тут є біотит але що нас насправді
цікавить Так Це більше стріблястих
вкраплень Які ви можете бачити ось тут у
нещодавно запатентованому процесі цей
літій відокремлюють від граніту і
очищують потім його потрібно додатково
переробити Але у Великій Британії немає
відповідних заводів для цього цілком
імовірно що карбонат літі буде
перероблятися в Європі А потім
доставлятися назад до Великобританії для
використання в акумуляторах і
транспортних засобах що виготовляється в
цій країні У нас є гігафабрики
Великобританії У нас є сировина тож
логічним наступним кроком буде
заповнення цієї прогалини всередині
цього ланцюжка І це стосується не лише
літію Велика Британія багата на критично
важливу сиро наприклад кембоурнська
гірнича школа у корновалі також
проводить дослідження кобальту нікелю та
вольфраму у вас має бути відповідна
геологія тож тут у корнуолі ми маємо
дещо дуже особливе і нам дуже пощастило
певний потенціал щодо ліцію деякі
родовища олова світового класу деякі
вольфрамові родовища світового класу і
тільки від нас залежить чи докладемо ми
зусиль аби використати цей потенціал
перш ніж старі шахти у корноолі зможуть
почати видобуток необхідно подолати ще
кілька перешкод але для Річарда Вільямса
важливо те що ця занепала галузь може
знову процвітати я гадаю що в місцевій
громаді зростає ентузіазм тому що всі
хочуть щоб ця шахта знову запрацювала
тут сильна гірничовидобувна спадщина і я
думаю що побачити як ця шахта ці копери
і корщатка знову запрацюють буде чимало
означати для місцевої громади Велика
Британія навряд чи подолає свою
залежність від інших країн найближчим
часом але вона зробила перші кроки до
відродження своїх
шахт іноді життя веде нас по шляху якого
ви ніколи не могли собі уявити Саме так
сталося із чіученомю шлях привів його із
тайваню до провінції в Туреччині де він
живе на кордоні сирією у місті
рейханли історик здійснив подвиг якому
позаздрили багато архітекторів він
побудував цей центр не маючи жодних
попередніх знань чи досвіду і відтоді
цей простір став дечим більшим ніж
просто будівлею він перетворився на
спільноту для біженців і місцевих
жителів спільноту яка слугує мостом між
культурами Бувають дні коли чученю не
може повірити що життя привело його сюди
до рейханли турецького муніципалітету що
межує із сирією за 8 000 км від його
дому
тайваню коли я прокидаюся я дійсно думаю
про те де я є і Яка моя робота Сьогодні
Яка Моя роль
сьогодні робота яку історик архітектури
провів тут уже мала феноменальний вплив
він заснував
тайвансько-рейханлійський центр для
громадян світу це проміннадії як для
сирійських біженців так і для місцевих
жителів дітей тут навчають турецької та
арабської мов А їхні матері виготовляють
ремісничі вироби щоб заробити гроші вони
навіть пропонують традиційний
далекосхідний масаж
спочатку Чіо планував лише провести
деякий час в університеті в анкарі але
потім тайванській благодійній
організації знадобився хтось хто міг би
побудувати школу для
біженців Я знаю як проводити дослідження
Я знаю як писати статті але ніколи не
будував
будівлі але с років тому я сказав Я
повинен
спробувати Тому що чим більше я
відвідував рейханли тим більше Я
відчував тамтешню темряву безнадію і
відчай і я казав собі Я знаю що не
впораюся точно не впораюся але я вирішив
я маю спробувати один
раз деякі з його друзів удома думали що
він збожеволів коли взявся за це
райханли неодноразово зазнавав ракетних
обстрілів і бомбардувань до кордону
всього кілька кілометрів Кожен другий
житель тут біжанець із Сирії і це не
кажучи про небезпеку яку становлять
землетруси
чіу прямує до
мерії мер швидко підтримав цей проект
заміж школи для сирійських дітей
вирішили побудувати громадський центр
для всіх мер ставиться до чіу із великою
повагою будівлі стають темою для розмов
лише тоді коли вони мають особливу
атмосферу і Чіо завжди каже я намагаюся
побудувати щось більше ніж просто
[музика]
будівлю за цей центр який був
побудований з бюджетом всього у 400 000
доларів Чіо отримав міжнародну
архітектурну
премію його Ідея полягала в тому щоб
використати масивні бетонні секції які
залишилися від турецького прикордонного
Муру фактично перетворивши бар'єр який
розділяв людей на центр що їх
об'єднує кожна така частина важить 11
тон і їхня основа дуже масивна це
означає коли станеться землетрус ця
будівля ніколи не завалиться І що більш
важливо якщо Одного дня сюди прийдуть
терористи смертники чи полетять ракети
ця будівля ця структура цей бетон з
подвійною металевою сіткою може
захистити від будь-якої подібної
атаки центр відвідують сотні людей щодня
у його майстернях ви
товари ручної роботи переважно для
тайванського ринку О навіть допомагав
розробляти дизайн цих шкіряних
сумок Тепер я щасливий тому що це справа
мого
життя багато хто з місцевих жителів
побоювався що біженцям тут надаватимуть
привілеї і чутки про це поширювалися
доти доки сусіди центру не познайомились
із чиу
особисто
говорили що сирійці отримують басейн і
футбольне поле щось таке але він видатна
людина з точки зору
людяності тут люди могли багато в нього
чому
навчитися коли ти розмовляєш з людьми ти
дивишся на них ти знаєш чого вони хочуть
знаєш що вони відчувають знаєш як вони
страждали знаєш що вони пережили і ти
знаєш як працювати разом І тут на
турецько-асирійському кордоні У тіочню
ще багато роботи в
тайвансько-рейханлійському центрі для
громадян
світу Невже європейці можуть залишитися
без улюбленої італійської справи
спагетті з молюсками фермери які
вирощують молюсків на північному
узбережжі Італії б'ють на сполух це тому
що новий загарбник загрожує екосистемі
дельтипо а саме звідти походить близько
40% молюсків для європейського
ринку рибалка емануела фіноті дедалі
більше впадає у вічай це нашестя знищує
його засоби до існування із
приголомшливою
швидкістю А на сьогодні це все дякуємо
за перегляди До зустрічі в наступному
випуску Європа у
[музика]
фокусі